[Musik]
hallo ihr lieben heute zeige ich euch
super leckere und total hübsche
yogurette cupcakes die cupcakes bestehen
neben leckeren schoko laden muffins auch
aus zwei toppings und wie einfach ich
die hergestellt habe das zeige ich euch
jetzt das erste topping das wir
herstellen besteht aus sahne und dies
ganz kalt und ganz frisch aus dem
kühlschrank außerdem doppel raum
frischkäse seine stand mitte und vanille
extrakt oder vanille zucker in unsere
schüssel geben wir jetzt zuallererst
frischkäse vanille extrakt und
schlagsahne
nun wird alles kurz auf niedriger stufe
verrührt bis es sich einigermaßen
verbunden hat anschließend geben wir
dass seine stand mit dem mit hinzu und
schlagen dass auf höchster stufe
komplett steif und somit ist unser
erstes frosting auch schon fertig ihr
seht ich habe kein weiteres
süßungsmittel verwendet bis auf das
vanille extrakt denn wir haben hier
anschließend noch die süßen schokoladen
streusel und das zweite topping das ist
auch schon süß genug und jetzt gebe ich
dieses topping in meinen spritzbeutel
läge das so lange in den kühlschrank und
zeige euch die nächsten zutaten für das
erdbeer forsting benötigen wir kalte
schlagsahne mascarpone magerquark
erdbeeren da könnt ihr frische oder auch
tief kehrt bernehmen außerdem
puderzucker und sahne stand mittel und
zu guter letzt vanille extrakt oder
vanille zucker für das frosting werden
die erdbeeren jetzt ganz kurz püriert
und dann geht es auch schon weiter
in eine ausreichend große schüssel geben
wir jetzt die mascarpone und den
magerquark
[Musik]
dann kommt noch dass vanille extrakt und
der puderzucker mit hinzu und zu guter
letzt die kalte schlagsahne
nun wird alles solange verrührt bis es
sich grob miteinander verbunden hat das
dauert auch gar nicht lange nach etwa
einer halben minute können wir schon
dass erdbeerpüree hinzugeben
[Musik]
hier achte ich noch darauf dass keine
großen stückchen hinein gelangen ihr
könnt die können natürlich auch gerne
mit erdbeer stückchen zu bereiten
allerdings lässt sich dann nicht so gut
auf spritzen jetzt fahre ich das ganze
noch mal ganz kurz miteinander und dann
gehen wir auch schon dass seine stand
mittel mit hinzu
[Musik]
nun können wir das ganze komplett steif
schlagen und durch die sonne stand
mittel wird das ganze auch schön sprits
fest
[Musik]
an der stelle gebe ich noch mehr
erdbeerpüree in die creme damit wir auch
eine richtig schöne rote farbe erhalten
die fertige creme gebe ich dann in
meinen spritzbeutel und zeige euch wie
ich die capex dekoriere
das rezept für meine schoko muffins
findet ihr übrigens schon auf einem
kanal das verlinke ich euch gerne unten
ihnen die infobox und auch noch mal hier
im bildschirm das erste frosting habe
ich jetzt rund aufgespritzt und gäbe
dass jetzt komplett in die
schokostreusel
[Musik]
das zweite frosting nämlich unser
leckeres apple frosting spritzen wir
jetzt mit hilfe einer offenen stelle auf
das erste frosting
zu guter letzt werden die cupcakes mit
angeschnittenen yogurette stückchen und
schokostreuseln dekoriert
[Musik]
die cupcakes sind nach dem dekorieren
sofort servieren bereit und halten im
kühlschrank bis zu drei tage
[Musik]
falls ihr jetzt auch richtig lust
bekommen habt ihr goretti cupcakes zu
backen dann schaut gern mal unten in die
infobox dort habe ich für euch die
genauen mengenangaben aufgeschrieben
[Musik]
diese cupcakes sind genau was für
diejenigen die schokolade und erdbeer
mögen oder generell yogurette fans sind
[Musik]
uns haben die yogurette cupcakes total
gut geschmeckt und sie waren auf jeden
fall ein hingucker
ich wünsche euch jetzt ganz viel spaß
beim nachbacken danke euch dass ihr bis
zum schluss dran geblieben seid und sagt
bis zum nächsten mal auf geht s kitchen